yeah hello and welcome with this video
yeah some games I want to play this
wonder what the time I could do um
something a little bit different
let's go for a longer game for a start
fifteen plus 15
[Music]
let's that's really long but it worked
quite well last time
just hope I'm no Kim Bing Raya Raya up
to Moloch
yeah let's see what happened
you
by the way if you notice behind me I
always have my keep it simple efore book
and now it has a nice green companion
the d4 one
young in crime and going to stick to
that books rapid form
Nydia three and basically
gee three against everything but not
against age six it's a bit too slow I
guess
so it's got h6 played
interesting
you
yeah h6 is not very useful but also not
hurting him all that much the question
is how I am benefit the most from this
move I can take on d5 and play Knight c3
this is often an idea using an
additional tempo in an otherwise
symmetrical position but I think it can
probably just pay Knight f6 and a6 and
we kind of okay
okay I'm going to play Quincy - I'm I'm
really not sure if I have something
special against us age six stuff
93 was of course possible but after 90
of 6 I have the same question what you
do
now
[Music]
a play g34 some sort of a Catalan setup
it makes some sense yeah as he does not
Bishop f5
you can also play Bishop f4 here
play for more classical setup lightly
we'll go 6 Bishop d6 against us
and age sixes
somewhat he was full spot
maybe now we can take community eggs and
Bishop f5
and makes quite a bit of sense actually
yeah and what what do we know now the
move age six looks silly but it is
probably not thick not completely
terrible
yeah they have been some experiments
recently with early age six moose in the
Queen's Gambit a six I mean and yeah
maybe we will soon see age six
you know okay I don't have any problem
or anything like that but I did not
manage to really call its opening set up
into question there should be six I'm
not certain if that is so great
I would rather gone to f5
kurung eform and then e six next here it
looks like he will move the bishop again
soon
you can go g6 of course that's a way to
develop
um
most of the time you play with something
like here like Bishop f5 and d6 and then
h6 actually is kind of useful yeah okay
he went to Bishop d5 um yeah I guess
2:55 is interesting maybe he simply
wants to take on f3 at the right moment
it is very likely once I have Knight c3
played the threat of e4 is so annoying
that he might take on f3
okay this is possible
be careful
Queen b6 maybe
that's probably his idea
you
No Queen b6 I expected hoof
v7 is attacked and
to play Queen b6
I will go night Biddy to a gas against
it
but surprised that he's
taking time for this decision
you
Wow that'sthat's very strange
you you almost never really want to move
the beep horn in combination with the
bishop somewhere here because that is so
weakening okay the most obvious replies
Knight c3 in this position
you
a form probably Bishop d5 I also have
Knight e5 but I think after Bishop d5
this might be still
kind of a cave of like a 93 looks
extremely extremely natural
I don't think he can allow me to simply
take the bishop that would completely
weaken the light squares like so much
that
only beyond repair
you
Jim
it is a general observation that usually
you don't want to move with the b-pawn
ever when you have the bishop somewhere
here on the Kings side when it is not
one b7 on b7 the bishop is often
covering the light squares and then you
can play a 65 later and free yourself
but now the bishop cm and that is really
not good to somebody to cover all the
pawns if you imagine I get to take this
thing on your form and then the long
diagonal he is open it is a really
really awful weakness on on the C file
yeah I'm curious what he's doing now I'm
threatening immediately to play 94 94
and 95 so the coupe's takes and 95
but this is a threat that he will
definitely take care of almost any
reasonable move would stop it anyway
something that is 6 for example yeah by
55 this is an interesting choice now
because both twin c2
and 90 x t5 is certainly better for
white
what they're continuations are better
Hawaii wins the to threaten z4
tough call
ninety-five I expect 25
then you move the Queen away and then
you have a huge discovery
later with the noid
tough call really
maybe this is even better it's really
hard to say
Quincy too is also very strong
you know expect Queen takes so okay
Queen takes would have Lisbon tempo and
poor gain
I move the Queen again
is there something better here than
cancelling the movie for is not
not out of the question but okay I will
probably have to castle anyway so let's
do it
yeah now efore and d5 this is what looks
like the most aggressive way to play
just opened a position up and try to
catch him in the center
[Music]
you know definitely extremely dangerous
a slow positional plays also not bad
ship t2 and Roxy one for example this is
some definitely
good
maybe a four let's go a for first
not easy for me to answer this move
he definitely does not want to take that
is strategically pretty much disaster
and their screen to be seven maybe a six
I take and then you have to he he would
need to take with the C pawn and also
would be pretty ugly
and before I go a form
he cannot even gone I'd be six to 285
Oh
you
okay
you
yeah Knight f6 looks like the only move
more or less
Knight b6 gets kicked by a five that
cannot be good
you
I'm not so certain what I do after
Knight f6 there there's there is
something super aggressive like d5
one
it's the normal let's say rookie 195
you know d5 is very tempting
going for an immediate kill
you
as it is really tough to not play this
mofo just
screams to be played
can pre-move eg5 if it takes it I will
take with you pawn
you
yeah 25 i am i will go queen it quincy
to
threatens all the discovered moves by
the night and Quincy aid
and night takes I don't actually know
what I'm doing probably 95
okay so Quincy - was my intended move
just wonder if there is something better
you
No
don't see anything better
you
winces six maybe
you
yeah Quincy six at least does not look
like an immediate kill
you
you
yeah he has to play Quincy's six I think
the threat to move the node and Quincy
aid
there's probably nothing else
you
now a simple way to have a huge
advantage is to take sorry to play
ninety four Quincy to ninety to ninety
five ninety three this is very
comfortable advantage
but I wonder if this is best you can
also take here and play 95 and wouldn't
the exchange that's also
certainly good
I have this feeling that there could be
and should be tripping more
you
I go to eat - let's keep the Queen's on
maybe queen a6
in a six what a move
you
Queen a6m it's probably what he has to
do
you
if we go to not trade down quindi one
maybe
yeah but then probably 96 and
I have probably nothing better than
winning the exchange
it's always tough to say if you have an
attack going if you should continue to
play with this tech and
even though you're not quite sure that
it's wins that you feel like you should
play in this more aggressive way or to
win material
always difficult probably here instead
of Queenie to taking a 95 winning the
exchange words are stronger he doesn't
have compensation for it I think
you
Queen a6 looks more or less forced and
kind of
surprised that he's having a decision
here
you
you
and order
what else is down
you
okay so I got
ninety-five would be the most obvious
move in
you
yeah it would be odd if it isn't good I
mean what does he do now
a simple issue he has said
almost
I mean where's the Queen going let me
let me do it like that yeah um if I now
take on d5 simply and then Queen takes
rook g1 you're not telling me that black
is surviving the set
this is kind of impossible
you
but I don't see how I'm killing him
Bishop d5 25:41 Quinby Sam looks
absolutely terrible but how do we win
you
roopd one immediately he will play
Bishop e7 I guess
again I don't see you win
[Music]
a couple
you
I don't see when Bishop takes Queen
takes rook t1 Queen b7 huh
looks pletely odd
see how I'm winning
maybe 85 is doing the trachea intending
a six
I want cream b5 if I can manage screen
b5 it's it's game over
okay come on let's do it I mean
I will play it at the end anyway so
even if I cannot figure out a concrete
win
it's just unlikely that I find something
that is looking clearly better
a home
really
hot cream b7
proposed the take-back okay
I mean I didn't quite see why Quincy I
mean 25 something like Bishop f4 is
probably killing him but
okay method was a six which he stopped
you
now can we
somehow
[Music]
you
I would like to prevent him from
castling that it's definitely
[Music]
definitely something that would help
we should be seven and castling that is
what he wants to do next
hmm
you
maybe I don't need to think about
I mean maybe I just can play normal
Muslim and just claim that he cannot
move
he's just completely stuck in his
position I'm thinking of Bishop e7 and
rook c1 and then we should be six the
night cannot move at all
that was one point of a five seeing if
he stops it with a six then I get the be
six square
in this particular case I wonder if I go
Bishop d6 what is requires because I'm a
threatening rook c7
and I don't quite see what he's doing
now
book c7 looks completely deadly
rook c8 I can take
and play Queenie for and Wakana it
cannot save himself
or itself
yeah maybe that was the right way to do
it not going for an immediate mate but
rather just play something normal and
cash in with a great position
no they cannot move anything
Luke c7 is pretty deadly
you
yeah so I want to take and play Queenie
for that should be
[Music]
would kill him off him
or queen f8 that is actually even
threatening on
f7 at the same
I don't think it matters much
we need for Queen f3 as it cannot save
the rook anyway even after Queen e4
there's no way to save the book
you
it begs and would don't see it actually
take back
a bit of a strange message him
maybe he wanted to resign enter
button
please don't let the clock run down it
would be awful
let me wait seven minutes iam
you
Joe
while he's waiting I can show you
something
now you made a more
okay
all right
yeah um take the look right
so how do we end the game
Bishop a7
No
but I wanted to show I was thinking he
was just letting the clock run down that
without actually me knowing that they
extended to say off my chest but on all
my courses right after the Black Friday
sale they started a Cyber Monday sale
I'm really not in the loop on all those
like Friday Cyber Monday whatnot I don't
really participate and in those kind of
things I know people just buy his stuff
or whatever like no tomorrow if those
days so they are they're really informed
I'm not I didn't know that's something
that like cyber monday exists even but
it just has the consequence that my
courses are on sale a little bit longer
so I thought it would enter today in the
morning but not the case
yeah it's too late now buddy no way to
save the material
you
yeah okay
you
um doodle
[Laughter]
you
yeah so
good
here right you see all my courses
including the Neiman's rogozin Corsair
still and I'm almost a whole farm page
it's nice didn't know that this is also
me in cooperation with Daniel bearish so
got half of the front page yeah so if
you want to get any of those corsets
yeah it's a good good time to do it
yeah
also if you like the other types of
videos I made a puzzle video or a chess
problem video I think the day before if
you liked it let me know it's always
good to get some feedback on different
video formats also what about time
control words having a game like this is
really nice I think once in a while one
drawback is that stuff like that can
happen you have some sorry some Joker
here who is now letting the clock run
down this is it can happen also in blitz
but at least it has some kind of time
limit I mean here it's completely
obvious that he's losing the house just
resigned buddy
you
you know I don't get that such a waste
of time
[Music]
ah
I've gotten again that nice ginger from
the my organic supermarket there this is
so great
Tootie it's so extremely tasty and the
testers nice mean Garden on what the
bride was it's very very spicy in a way
very nice
much better than the cheaper the cheap
gin job
you
yeah and ages later
[Music]
you
hopefully I mean the thing is if they
let the clock run down they get some
kind of - school on on only chess but
you
yeah okay what is doing is this
nonsensical stuff we can never look at
the game a little bit so
maybe maybe I should play Knight c3 and
try to exploit h6 in some other way
this is not really fantastic him he
could have played Bishop f5 and this was
cannot I cannot analyze the game is
still running Bishop f5 I think this is
a bit better than Bishop e6 even though
this might not be at the end of the
world this one yeah and this is I think
pretty awful
you should just play Queen b6 and I
don't see anything bad happening to
black Queen b6 I would probably play
Knight B d2
and then the position is approximately
equal maybe maybe widest marginally
better but it's nothing special before
maybe five forever is oh no I'm sorry B
5 forever is better for Wyatt
and pretty substantially so the big
question is they are either this or
Quincy two means the to the threatening
efore and also looks very strong I
couldn't quite determine what's better
but night Texas is ultimately good I
thought you would play Queen d5 in this
position because I don't want to take
necessarily after seat xt5 I'm better
but it's not so clear they would have
moved the Queen I thought that it's
better than night eggs because yeah you
get immediately hit and here the
question is how strong was d5 it looks
very very it looks like the right move
we have a very powerful trying to break
through in the center but a slower move
like okay one is definitely also strong
yeah and here I can already win some
material after Quincy - Quincy 6 looks
like the only move I can take again I
cannot move take 95 wins the exchange
maybe this is strongest
but this is also not bad and the the
upside is if it works yeah it is really
really really strong no one threatening
eight six no I think this is pretty much
win
you know I've if
take back yeah so what an idiot ooh
sorry I'm just calling it now I mean I
want to be polite but people like that
really wrecked mine no fear the nice
thing is I have had this kind of stuff
and then they asked for a rematch this
is this is the best thing to do we are
asking for a rematch how can I block him
block him smell
leave
to block the sky
yeah just a waste of time of everybody
involved I don't get it ready but some
people I just immensely immensely I
don't know
okay so um let's go for some more blitz
games maybe
may our debt rock
let's try something unconventional
you
he's playing very quickly
you
I went for a double oven kettle some
it's rarely seen variation but it is not
too bad
white um has an advantage but it is
nothing
out of the ordinary
you
came I think I'm going to take
expect pawn takes okay
can school
94 and rate this one I don't mind to
trade one or two pieces
quite a bit less space
now I'm threatening c5 just winning a
piece so very likely even move the Queen
it's not so clear where the Queen should
go because I also have this idea to take
on d4 and take on it too
yeah this is one of them moves that
stops this idea
[Music]
three
you
Queen g5 for sediment
we are not
it's not very dangerous
okay
yeah I thought Queen g5 was a bit more
of a problem now
but he didn't didn't quite things the
same so cringy five what is what is his
reply
[Music]
so you just going f3 and
that
[Music]
you
yeah at the end of the day c7 is hanging
some
something that I have to take into
account but it's still a bit too
tempting let's move
you should g3 I go h4 that was the idea
why I went h5 in the first place
whatever three is not so clear
you
Oh
that move I didn't even that didn't even
register as a legal move to me
so if I go Queen f5 what's going on
you
or does he ever cover all this f Queen
8/3 now
on j-3 like
no contrary though what's interesting
I mean it looked ungodly ugly but maybe
it was still playable
now
you
always is-7 hanging at the end yeah
[Music]
you
ninety-seven
this okay
I thought 97 and then rugby aid was my
idea okay here I'm just taking
takes rook dat looks like
did pretty awful self pin
you
No
okay one now coming
you
No
don't think here to play this f3 move I
didn't quite see it actually at first
Shakir f3 is maybe an issue here
f3
when I can go back here
okay this is very strong and the one
point is that probably this ad this this
and Nyjah for line like that is winning
from lack yeah you cannot take it
because of made which only leaves look F
true and then I can take and then now
I'm winning everything here okay so
let's go for another game
mmm I run out of tea that is early
let's go for one more game
gorgeous
you
I will get
okay not a green felt it but almost
this is one of the rare cases where I
suggest to him
bassy 3 because the idea to go for afor
is pretty nice actually
a 44
you should f5 Wow okay
okay so we've got a stone wall
in the Stonewall you just put your
Knights on D 3 and F 3 and enjoy a
slight advantage this is a very simple
approach but one that nevertheless works
pretty nicely if their blunder g6 is
even better
it's kind of a non game rematch maybe
yeah
you
ok it's a bit of an uncommon line
you
okay maybe my move order wasn't
very precise
the night is hanging and
addition
five square looks a bit weak
you
you
we had to play Bishop e6 first or
something
you
you
it looks pretty bad actually that is a
pretty bad position
I already made a mistake there with my
order
played a bit too quickly
you
yeah this is the thing
you
he's playing too quickly he's not
playing it in the best possible way
the Queen has probably already misplaced
them
[Music]
how do we handle this
[Music]
you
you know the query go efore and
completely cut the Queen off
it's got f3 though this is the thing
[Music]
can also play before and take on not
quite almost take on c2
- 36 seconds he played instantly every
single movie played instantly
you
the time is basically forcing me to
stop their commentary
I think I'm okay I mean that would be
odd if not with all the pieces being as
active as they are
[Music]
he has a hard time to move any of his
pieces really
you
or queen c1
and for Roxy one
I mean yes he cannot move anything
Knight is stuck on b1
you
I will play Roxy one almost no matter
what
you
I don't see anything really that that he
can threaten in her indisposition
you
didn't see this move
you
that seemed how do we win
I'm is really awful
playful meteor actually the be good
nine seconds
you
[Music]
yeah I'm probably not winning this which
is which is awful really
considering how the game went
you
I got no time ready to calculate this
you
you
ah
you
yeah I'm losing this terrible terrible
really
after such an
and you know it's just completely done
here after Luke Siwon and I still
managed to bungle this up yeah you have
to find something good here probably
just to I mean that that is winning in
many ways but the thing is I only have
13 seconds this is their only problem I
spend so much time at the beginning
and once he has now I've also given away
the HDH porn which is a big problem as
then my king is so weak yeah I just need
a little bit more time like go here
it's also probably relatively easy then
to win the a porn is always stopped on a
7 and I just have to activate the night
somewhere yeah it was it was a bit awful
because I I screwed up the move over
here I should play probably Bishop d6
first and this is a bit awful now I have
to find something to even stay in the
game and what what he did here is just
bad
which is bad chess gauge e4 is strong
and this is just bad we have seven and
this is this whole stuff is just pretty
awful white is completely outplayed
really a shame because I managed even
with no time to completely turned this
game around and then okay now 96 and f5
is - a million yeah this is this is
pretty nice yeah that that shows how bad
Queen h7 was
No okay so one more game and then don't
want to end with this with this awful
performance
now Josep onine has to suffer
but
or will his fault but now he has to
suffer
you
it's a fairly normal
ruler pests kind of position
fairly okay for like
- too quickly actually due to the game
before
always
little batil to sheriff you
if you play such a game which is after
the screwed up first move so one-sided
and you're still manage to lose
really awful
I'm trying to double behind the afford
either that's a well-known motif
one well-known game with this ideas the
first match game
1992 the do rematch between fish and
Spassky
was far more effective when Fischer
played it but
not bad for white
active tonight b6
he's got
lot on the queenside
trying to
[Music]
make something happen on the kingside
Oh
okay maybe it is completely harmless
what I would have here on the kingside
but
it's very relaxed about it
you
okay so this stops coming to g4
you
I don't really get
this is over to that side of the board
that easily
okay let's go Queen f3
it takes a seven I have okay seven that
looks that looks dangerous
you
hey I was thinking to move the night and
then queen g3 h4 it's still very slow
you
okay
we cover that for the moment
you
um that is not good for him
anything in particular and he is
defending well
[Music]
once to go have six no one-and-a-half 96
basically all of the time
you
we need for maybe finally finally gets
have a threat
yeah I didn't didn't play this well this
is so not not a good game
you
even if I get to age seven I mean moves
the rook the rook somewhere and then I'm
not really threatening all that much
now but she seems concerned he seems
concerned
you
okay so but this is this is a bit risky
that is a bit risky I mean the rukon the
third is really important so check
and this one
I don't think he saw this idea at all
I don't see a defense really
well no way he blundered this on the
third-ranked okay so I'm going to stop
the video I'm a bit tired anyway um I
hope you enjoyed it there was a longer
game at the very beginning and then sub
blitz with some good and some bad
moments I'll be back soon enough
thanks for watching